one thing that we've never guessed by
looking at you I'm not a rapper
hey I'm cambrie and you're watching
certifier country with Sophie shoelaces
[Music]
welcome back to certified country I'm
Sylvia Lacey and today we are talking
love songs and painful ink with none
other than cane brown but before we
start let me get you up to speed on
canes backstory because it is truly
incredible cane just turned 24 and he
has gone from homeless to an Idol and X
Factor cast-off to a YouTube and social
media sensation scoring a major label
record deal and then debuting at number
one with his very first album after
opening for Jason Aldean and Chris Young
this summer Cain released a deluxe album
and made history as the first artist
ever to top all five Billboard country
charts at the same time when he's not
shaking up the country music industry
Kane is serving up couple's goals with
his fiance Kaitlyn they are getting
married next fall Cain spilled all the
adorable details when we sat down at the
Sony Music offices in Nashville
Tennessee
there's so much awesome stuff going on
with you you're getting married you're
engaged how's the wedding planning going
she's doing it and I'm saying yeah
that's the correct answer
yeah I told her I'll just get a tug show
up and say I do mm-hmm
[Music]
how did you know she was the one um
she's literally just like me very like
she wears all my clothes she thinks all
my clothes are cool she wishes she can
wear my shoes she's funny
we get along all the time and she loves
music as much as I do
as she solid source of inspiration for
you on a regular basis oh yeah so this
has been a huge career milestone for you
right now with what ifs what is the next
big milestone that you're looking
forward to yeah
keep them coming okay so let's talk
about the next single what's next after
what ifs releasing song called heaven
everybody's talking about heaven like
they just can't wait to go saying now
it's gonna be so good
oh it's just like a love story they're
like a bunch of girls want their guys to
say to him yeah Kevin makes them too and
uh basically this talk about my fiancee
does your fiance ever get emotional with
your music she did over her sorrow for
called what's mine is yours to play like
50 times I kind of got tired of it
what's mine is here
chores I made in my sound crazy
my pain
in the big of
if you say me I love all of your tattoos
so I want to do a little thing called
tattoo tales your first tattoo I was a
Bible verse on my chest when I turned 18
I was John 3:16 your last tattoo my last
tattoo is this rose my worst
painful tattoo was it the most painful
it looks like it thank you I think cuz
it's my dominant hand like this in hurt
but it doesn't have as many nerves
because I use this one all the time okay
so I guess not like my hand swelled up
like it was bad doesn't mean anything or
you just liked the way it looked
is my fiance's middle name bruised yeah
so that's what I say is for even though
it's not I got it I make her feel
special that's a good story
aim your favorite tattoo favorite tattoo
you probably my rose on my wolf I
thought some people on your team have
the wolf too huh one person too what is
the wolf signify for you well we're just
like we're like a family and it kind of
goes back to that movie where they do
The Hangover I thought wait a second
could it be and now I know for sure I
just added two more guys to my wolf pack
do you have any that you regret I said I
regret this Chinese symbol and my music
notes but if I didn't have them I'd be
in the Army right now so it's kind of
like you know God was looking out for me
the last one is your next tattoo I don't
know I've been wanting to touch you for
a while but I'm still hurting for this
one does it after you get one and it
hurts really bad does it kind of push it
off for a little while longer
yeah what depends again pain tolerance
is Hartman's not
[Music]
for like honor
[Music]
okay one more little rapid-fire round
for you this one's called the country
quickie and it's just a few rapid-fire
questions to get to know I know I see
your face not like that might out of the
gutter first concert you attended
Christian got Daisy
first album that you purchased Krysia
song currently spitting on a repeat I
have been listening to heaven a lot do
you rock out to your own music
[Music]
if you weren't an artist you'd probably
do be doing what probably working at
physics yeah yeah my favorite job before
this one thing that we've never guessed
by looking at you I'm not a rapper the
deluxe album is out now are you thinking
about the next full length are you
working on that one yeah we're about to
start writing soon I'm excited I kind of
found my core routers that I want to
write with and I told them so we've got
a couple dates booked that we all get to
write the other very cool and you're
about to go out on the road again with
Chris Young yeah tell me about getting
back together with him um it'll be
awesome we didn't get to really write on
the Jason tour but I feel like we'll get
to ride on his next one and then lanco
is gonna be with us they already have a
hit record but it'll be even bigger hit
record whenever they come out so it'll
be cool it'll be a very fun tour thank
you so much for watching if you liked
what you saw click the link in the
description and ring the bell you never
miss an episode of certified country I
promise you will not regret it we've got
some really really fun stuff coming up I
will see you guys again next Friday
right here on YouTube